un gobierno de alto nivel sin alianzas
políticas esa es la visión que el
presidente serio mataré la tiene para
italia tras semanas de agitación
política y mientras el país se enfrenta
al coronavirus y a su peor crisis
económica en décadas
alberto por tanto el smi deberá hacer un
llamado a todas las fuerzas del
parlamento para que otorguen su
confianza a un gobierno de alto nivel no
vinculado a ninguna fuerza política
identificarse con alguna fórmula
política esta etapa requiere un gobierno
sólido y nexo de su función o el hombre
encargado de la misión sería el ex jefe
del banco central europeo mario draghi
que no es ajeno a la crisis
apodado supermario el economista
italiano tiene el mérito de haber
salvado a la eurozona en el punto más
álgido de la crisis de deuda en 2012 si
es elegido como primer ministro tendrá
mucho trabajo por hacer
estaría fue uno de los primeros países
europeos en verse afectado por la
pandemia hasta ahora han muerto más de
89 mil personas la economía se contrajo
un 8.9 por ciento en 2020
la peor recesión desde la segunda guerra
mundial y el año pasado se perdieron más
de 420 mil puestos de trabajo incluidos
más de 100.000 solo en diciembre draghi
sería el encargado de elaborar el plan
de recuperación de italia que estuvo en
el centro de los enfrentamientos dentro
del gobierno saliente y que llevaron a
la dimisión del ex primer ministro josep
conté la semana pasada mataré la espera
que el nuevo gobierno sea respaldado por
el parlamento advirtiendo que la
celebración de elecciones anticipadas
dejaría a italia en un estado de caos
durante un momento crucial